trey lance as we talked about earlier
318 pass attempts is the fewest for a
first round qb in the history of the nfl
who was second as far as a first round
qb
it's a tough one okay
is it tough yup think hang on
hang on don't give me a hand okay
tim tebow oh that's a good guess though
that's a good guess it's michael vick
michael vick and then that's followed by
mark sanchez but i i like where you were
thinking there you're right you mean
think about a quarterback that's running
and doing that type of stuff all that
but the big thing is like four years
that's what we're doing exactly right
that's right i just wanted to mention
tim tebow because i knew matt casey
would want me to mention tim tebow today
well oddly enough
i'm glad that what comes through this
can't be picked up by the microphone
oddly enough
my first pick of the drat for the big
kahuna's draft
this guy's idol growing up was tim tebow
and that is trey lance that's the i
don't care pick number three is the the
big kahuna pick of the draft for me yes
you know it with all the scrutiny around
who should you pick what should you do i
don't know
and you picked a guy
that hasn't played a lot of football
played one double a football added on
top of that you know hasn't had a ton of
reps throwing the football and all that
so that to me was the big kahuna pick of
the draft right there because that's
something that of course yeah shanahan
lynch their names are going to be tied
to this forever there's no doubt about
that so
i'm interested to see you know where
this goes and and how how uh trey lance
develops going forward
yeah look what what made it even more
kahuna ish
the idea that
that they all the stuff kind of revel in
the uncertainty and the rogers stuff we
got this third overall pick and we we
called the packers about aaron rodgers
and
and and leading people to believe it was
mack jones that was all gratuitous that
was all unnecessary they were not going
to get leap frog for trey lance it was
trevor lawrence zack wilson and then the
49ers controlled the board that's that's
moved up there that's where i don't
still believe it was i don't believe it
was originally for trey lance that's
where i i you i will i don't believe it
i still think it was mack jones because
they were worried about new england and
carolina and i think that
shanahan's mind was changed some
somewhere in the process
i am still a believer that that trade
was made to go to get mac jones
originally
and chris we've now seen twice
in four years
someone in that organization has the
ability to get kyle shanahan to change
his mind because he was all in on kirk
cousins 2018 and i know maybe they
weren't going to get him but if they're
determined to get him they're going to
get him he didn't get much more in free
agency than they paid jimmy garoppolo to
keep him around right but they got him
to pivot to garoppolo somebody said the
right thing at the right time to get him
to pivot to garoppolo even though he'd
never worked with garoppolo you know
garoppolo had a hard time staying
healthy through four opportunities in
2016 he got injured in game two and now
if it's true that he wanted mac jones
initially
somebody got him to pivot toward trey
lance so there's somebody in that
organization that knows how
to push the buttons just right of kyle
shanahan to make him come to the
conclusion that someone else wants him
to come to yeah maybe mike i mean you're
right
the the garoppolo thing with the cousins
thing listen i don't know the whole
story there i can at least say at a base
level and back at the time a little bit
you know i think there was they were all
in 10 they were panicked a little bit
like oh man in our first year are we
gonna go oh and 16 and i think they felt
like they didn't have a quarterback on
the roster that could actually win them
a football game so i think maybe that's
where they rushed a judgment on the
jimmy garoppolo thing and got that going
uh that that's that's what i believe
happened really there and and i can
understand that for where they were at
that point but you're right mike i don't
know somebody somebody's got shanahan's
ear for sure in that organization
well for me the ultimate kahuna move
last night four years after getting
burned by trading up and taking a
quarterback in mitchell trubisky ryan
pace does it again getting up even more
giving up next year's first round pick
to get justin fields as he had slid out
of the top ten that is gutsy that is all
in and that is an organizational kahuna
move because as we said earlier the
message to the bears fans now is we've
got this okay quit quit asking us to
fire ryan pace and matt nagy it's not
happening we're going to see what justin
fields can be we're going to take our
shot here that we have a franchise
quarterback that can lead us to where we
want to go if it doesn't work out then
yeah
the next time they draft a quarterback
it won't be ryan pace or matt nagy
working for the team or maybe team
president ted phillips he may be tied to
this one too yeah maybe maybe you're
right it's a gutsy pick it really is and
you know it's uh
yeah for a team they they need a
difference maker at this position
something to get the city to rally rally
around their team a little bit and feel
faith in the quarterback and all of that
but yeah overall
big time move but brian page really he's
the one that big kahuna's there to pull
pull uh pull that off last night for
sure
um
i think the next one i'm gonna go to is
and we haven't talked about it i want to
spread the wealth in the conversation
here
is the raiders and their pick you know
with leatherwood at 18. that to me was
you know i thought leatherwood would be
going in the first round i had him in
baltimore later in the first round uh i
wasn't sure i didn't think he'd go that
early i mean that was i think
a pretty big time gutsy pick by them we
know they needed an offensive lineman
for sure they've let a lot go out the
door here with trades and the trent
brown and rodney hudson and all that
gabe jackson leatherwood fits the mold
of what they had just uh he's maybe the
best run blocker in the draft so that's
where you got to be excited they're
going to be able to put him at guard
right now and just go run people over
and open up holes and he'll be fine he
has the potential to be
a really big time franchise tackle he
does his pass protection was a little
less than than what you would like but
uh yeah that was a gutsy pick maybe
overdrafting a little bit but there was
a big need there for their football team
and they believe in the guy
i'll say the philadelphia eagles in
jumping up to get devonta smith when you
consider big picture what they did
dropping from 6 to 12 picking up a first
rounder next year assuming the risk that
the dolphins would take devonta smith or
someone else before the eagles could get
him would take him and then having that
plan to jump the giants when it became
evident that the giants were all in on
devonta smith they get a guy who weighs
166 pounds but you know what they had
desean jackson they're not concerned
about having a short and skinny slim
reaper wearing number three most likely
for the philadelphia eagles unless he
can get number six away from khalil tate
yeah uh i mean it is it's a big time
move for them as a football team he's a
he's a star there's no doubt and the
only thing is that skinny aspect that
you talked about but as i said earlier i
know there's some teams that had devante
smith as the number one receiver on the
board and were just blown away by what
he can do and i think the eagles were
probably one of those football teams so
good for them and they got somebody for
jalen hurts to air it out to for sure
now i mean i kind of want to go with
like
i want to go with like almost two guys
here to cheat a little bit i don't mean
to cheat but it's just like
i want to go with the two pa like the
two pass rushers at the end the saints
and the bills those were kahuna picks to
me you know first off let's just start
with the saints peyton turner you talked
about most teams had him like in a
mid-round draft pick i don't know if he
was that low for me i think is he's a
guy i looked at as to be a mid to late
second round pick but yeah that's a
gutsy pick because i don't think anybody
had him going in the first round you
know there are some traits there as far
as being a big twitchy athlete he's a
lot like marcus davenport honestly the
way he's built and the way he plays it
reminds me of him so that was kind of
unexpected and uh yeah that'll be under
a microscope and i want to do the same
thing with the bills if you don't mind
mike just with gregory rousseau because
again it's a projection pick there's
nothing you can watch on film to go
oh this guy's just a killer and
dominates there there's not that it's a
little bit more like a danielle hunter
right who i think at lsu his senior year
or last year there he had a one sack and
a half this guy is long he's not
involved in every play doesn't dominate
all that way opted out last year the
year before that when he did play i know
he had like eight or nine sacks but they
weren't like oh he died fifteen and a
half
either way sorry sorry either way i
don't care this is not very few of them
were just beating the guy mike like it
was all like hey i'm standing here the
quarterback's got a lot of time to throw
somebody else missed the sack and i'll
go get him now or hey the quarterback's
been back there for seven seconds and
now i finally got there to get the sack
you know i think booger mcfarlane kind
of made those points last night there
were underwhelming sacks so it is a
projection and i think a gutsy pick by
the bills but they they need that
position
he is a giant he is i was amazed to see
him
next to michael senora from the nfl
league office who's about my height and
he towered over him right 5 10 5 11 ish
i don't know if i'm shrinking yet or not
and then as david shaw the stanford
coach pointed out during the nfl network
coverage as rousseau walked out and he's
up on the elevated platform and fans are
down there reaching for him he was able
to slap their hands without bending over
that's how long his arm yeah that's why
you take them this guy this guy uh to
buffalo uh
it could be interesting to see what
happens all right for me since you went
with two and since i got the last pick
i'm going with two the bang bang back to
back running backs from najee harris to
pittsburgh and then travis ctn to the
jacksonville jaguars if you're going to
use these guys i'm fine with it you you
but you got to use them otherwise you're
wasting a first round pick you could
have gotten a running back later so it's
a gutsy move to put any running back
name on a card the steelers did it for
need the jaguars did it for luxury
because it was just last year as we said
earlier they got james robinson
undrafted so uh all in moves
to try to help their passing game
with the two best running backs and it
was a question whether either of them
would go in round one uh but now both of
them go i i wonder
if the steelers hadn't taken najee
harris would the jaguars have taken him
or atm i
i would think atn was their cup of tea
just because of
you know if he comes from an offense
that's similar to what urban meyer ran
himself and i just think he fits that
mold a little bit more where i think
pittsburgh is looking to get hey big ben
get underneath the center we're going to
pull a guard here and let naji harris
follow him up in the hole i think he
fits that style a little bit more so
yeah i i think both teams got what they
want uh with with that position
and there was very little secret in
circles about not jay harris going to
the steelers if anybody wanted him they
could have jumped him no anything any
other ones jump out to you like the i i
mean i wanted the baltimore ravens
you know their picks at the end of the
first round the fact that they didn't
trade down right right right they used
them they used them they got a receiver
who can do a little bit of everything
you know and he's he was a tough eval
because two years ago he was awesome
last year was kind of just like eh
and i think you heard last night i mean
a lot of people think covet affected him
and all those type of things but i love
the second pick jason away off the edge
for that defense i mean to me the ravens
just added leonard floyd to their
defense and i think that sounds pretty
good if you're a ravens fan
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports